ciao ragazzi benvenuti all'ultima
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è cambiamenti che questa
puntata così importante o da subito
avuto è chiaro chi volevo qui al mio
fianco ed è per questo che sono contento
di invitare all'interno degli studios
the casa mia per l'ultima volta tutto
quanto il wil woosh chin chao
allora ragazzi siamo pronti per questa
puntata
non ho capito bene io a dire a questo
punto di iniziare ad ascoltare i nostri
audio i vostri i vostri 33 anni a casa
dei miei disoccupata quello ucciderli ho
preso i pochi soldi che ho detto padoan
ieri si trattava per forza qualche
lavoro prendo un'altra dell affitto è
tolto tra le città abbastanza atene
affitto trovato lavoro e dopo tre mesi
non mi hanno rinnovato il contratto e
sono andata da dei miei primo diretta
sembrava tanto spera solo che io lo
sapevo purtroppo questa storia sappi che
nella nostra vita almeno abbia avuto
contratti rinnovati molte molte volte
eppure questo qui ci ha fatto smettere
per il cazzo duro mai ma prendi il tempo
per ricaricarsi dopo che la vita di
tromba perché arrivato il momento dei
tre partite la vita per poi per la mente
mio cambiamento più grande si offre
consiglio affondano a pale fosse e gip
di lucca 6 cui seconds abidal e due box
e si striscione di tale controllo e su
tutte le reali se invece si sono altro
che balle rocco un apporto equa della
verde e arrivando al territorio ragazzi
la battono interrotto mentre stava
cercando un audio capisci il francese si
le capisco
come si può tradurre quel che viene
detto angelo il famoso angelo arrivare
ad una nuova lingua o comunque come
supercazzola che sia ben accetto in quel
momento il più grande per me credo sia
stato quello di decidere e andare in
terapia da uno psicoterapeuta ed è il
più bel percorso che mi ha mai deciso di
intendere i ragazzi lo psicologo
dovrebbe essere una cosa tipo il medico
di base che dovrebbe ri avevo dentro il
mio cussina ore anzi chi è che dice no
io non ho bisogno dello psicologo
psicoterapeuta che sia sta mentendo
pecca di superbia avere un ascoltatore
diciamo è un bene secondo me la
psicoterapia è una cosa che ti permette
non solo di comprendere quali sono i
tuoi dati magari pd precisi quali
lavorare ma anche i lati di forza è
un'occasione mancata che io l'ho mai
fatto niente di tutto ciò che capita
greca pure dal terapeuta
ma cosa fate andata male mi sembra un
gruppo così disfunzionale mi sembrano
persone disfunzionale all'interno di un
gruppo solite professionale
guardate scoperto in faccia però forse
io l'ho grossi cambiamenti possono
vivere
vogliamo che qualcuno dobbiamo farcela
dobbiamo sentire stavano c'è il motivo
di vivere un dono siamo incatenati
giusto commento nel cesso interno ha
ascoltato solo con le magliette in
faccia vedrà il cambiamento più
significativo nella mia vita era
regalare di stato è stato tre anni fa
quando io la scusa di provincia di un
paese ridotto
mi sono trasferita in inghilterra ne è
completamente cambiata la vita ho
iniziato a recitare più me stessa i miei
genitori fortunatamente hanno imparato
ad accettarlo e auguro a tutti ragazzi
che hanno problemi di guardare al di
fuori dell'italia perché in italia non
c'è purtroppo il futuro da questo punto
di vista alcuno tutti loro di riuscire a
fare accettare questi cambiamenti
interni granelli comandava vi farete
questo ha fatto che lei pensi che in
italia non ci sia è una garanzia per il
futuro come la vedi alla mi lascia molto
interdetto perché da una parte in di
capisco assolutamente non in generale
perché ci sono delle realtà
effettivamente che magari non sono
quelle che viviamo noi che potete anche
immaginare o che posso anche immaginare
al calore del quale impossibile vivere
ea volte veramente la fuga è l'unico
modo in realtà per andare a trovare un
po come le rondini una primavera ad oggi
quello che mi sento di dire che mi trovo
nella condizione e nelle necessità per
cui l'italia per quanto per certi versi
imbarazzante
non mi pesa anzi l'unica cosa che mi
spinge a fare cercare di renderla un
popolo che posso fare un posto che
accetta di più o meno chiuso di mento
interessa stare bene
la forza cerca di far stare bene altre
persone che non hanno la possibilità di
andarsene
credo che all'interno di una realtà come
la sua forse sia stata l'unica scelta a
me piace pensare in realtà che l'italia
possa crescere che stia crescendo e che
semplicemente bisogna in qualche modo
darle tempo sono il primo a dire che
quello che questo tempo non dovessimo un
futuro collimare con quelle che saranno
le mie esigenze che non sono brevi e
adesso ovviamente da raggiungo allunga
di migliore vivi anni alì terme intero
cambiamento non sopporta la monotonia e
la routine quindi ogni tanto devo
cambiare soprattutto colore di capelli
ho studiato una materia umanistica e
sono andata a lavorare in ambito
artistico quindi devo sempre cambiare
non fa definire vita buttata anche noi
dobbiamo cambiare il più debole e
finisce in un certo senso un pochino
come una fenice muore per risorgere
dalle proprie ceneri spar anziché le
idee abbiamo per il futuro vi possano
piacere io sono nata cresciuta e pensavo
anche che sarei morta all'interno delle
prende maglie del diritto e ora lavora
in un ambiente artistico che capisco
perfettamente comunque il cambiamento
per sunto non battete dentro ma parte
dalla capacità di riuscire a cavalcare
quello che succede esternamente la cosa
migliore è un po come dicembre ogni
giorno per il frigo vedere che cosa ti
offre la vita e fare impianto migliore
che riesce a tirar fuori in questo modo
verranno sempre al tuo locale 20 anni di
relazione con un uomo anche figlia di
quattro anni fa scoperto ti induce una
vita parallela in cui lei è omosessuale
di matrimonio finito chiaramente lui non
ha mai né a me il solo dovuto mettere di
fronte al fatto compiuto
sono che partita da sola adesso un
compagno andiamo molto ma so che possa
andare avanti da sola a ma brava bravate
di s la cosa più bella di quando ti
arriva una bidonata
sulle gemme che quando ti rialzi ti
rendi conto di essere invincibile
parlamento più belle della mia vita ho
fatto diventare mamma cercato di
diventare mamma per di charlie ma non
ero pronta a diventare mamma di tre
gemelli maschi chiamo quasi trainante
jared homan ma tutte le tecniche salsese
si sono tre gemelli splendidi torelli
iniziamo col domande la prima la faccio
io preferiresti vivere in uno scantinato
senza finestre e nutrirti di insetti e
muschio e ti si forma sotto le ascelle
per i prossimi dieci anni di vita o
morire oggi oppure essere una bellissima
alga libera di scorazzare tra le onde
della barriera corallina con l'ansia di
venire è divorato da una tartaruga da un
momento all'altro questa è veramente
neanche una vita un po più emozionante
ma io soffro di a scegliere la prima
ligure scegliere la prima anche perché
ormai i cambiamenti climatici le cordate
ferirlo distrutte io invece sono pronta
ad assumermi ogni giorno il rischio
dalla famosa de gaulle antezza vuoi
mettere anche marino dei celibi un'alga
vorrei dare enrico la loggia da marco
preferiresti essere obbligato a mangiare
con posate con poste dalla compressione
di unghie sporche di piedi di anziano
che non hanno mai visto l'acqua o
nutrirsi delle tue unghie altamente
proteiche per via della ricotta che si
grattano all'unghia edito a un
bellissima domanda rega io quelle mie
unghie ce magno per tutta le mie
finanziato solo posate in cui mangio
cibo normale certo la prima
la prima è fatto magari alla porchetta
pure quel sapore non lo zio epico e poco
subito una spalmata dell'unghia scelto
le mie unghie ma che schifo e livorno
scelgo quello dell'anziano anche se ogni
scena prima di detti risolvere qualsiasi
problema di piccole vasta scala senza
che chi venga riconosciuto il problema
ormai nessuno per merito lo è per un
totale inetto e appropriati delle idee
degli altri
risultando il salvatore del popolo posso
chiedere miggiano diventato il merito il
proprio in solving false quotidiano
imbarazzante la seconda prima cotta
guardatemi la schiena e la prima
assolutamente la prima e reagisce subito
e animate mi vorrà chiamare cassandra è
la prima non sono merda ecco scalpo di
star cercando solo intelligente della
persona che sta alla tua destra
proseguendo in senso orario o perché
vogliono leggere la tv sta a sinistra
come quando in senso antiorario cosi io
già so niente
parla dispiace per 2 2 che non potete
sceglierne a me piace più per me è
sempre passate che non saprei scegliere
le somme fa malissimo tutte già maturati
una bellissima intelligente
ma ben 38 nazioni e nico fa paura la sua
intelligenza appaiono capisci non ne fa
più paura anche quella di latina a chi
ti porta essere capito bene che è una
parte della io seguo 50 e 50 avessi
avuto che ne so guglielmo e graziana ok
nella paramatti graziana ok ma la pancia
vicino né graziana né gianmarco invece
forse scelgo graziano oddio la sanità ma
siccome noi ragazzi sono io scelgo
lavinia la mia insegnamento e una croce
di graziana grazie al segnale gianmarco
enrico da solo andata mi sono sentito io
lo conosco bel rigo enrico sarebbe più
intelligente in questa sala limits
lermani usa la pillola giannini nulla
togliere giammarco ma frena gli emboli
ultimata non appena ultimate niente da
raccontare dal guardaroba che vorresti
essere la persona più ricca del mondo
senza poterti accoppiare con anima viva
mantenendo quindi la verginità o essere
uno straccione con la capacità di portar
di chiunque di voi ha letto era facile
da bere troppo debole quindi io scelgo
la tracina da sesso ogni giorno in cui
qualcuno potrà offrire qualcosa dentro
casa mia farò un po povera e altri ma
ricco di gran lunga la prima ipotesi che
ti ho sceglierei la seconda ma scelgo la
prima perché la gran troppi casi
letteralmente e psicologicamente
cioè se io potessi non avere la spinta
erotica io vivrei in vita dal genio
sogno di ore io da marika lancio la
serenità alla tranquillità l'estrema
ricchezza e l'opportunità di raggiungere
una vita da scelta piuttosto
la difficoltà vive ogni giorno godermi
si trovare chiunque ma comunque
all'interno di una realtà che sarebbe
sempre con un bisogno e motivo né nei
confronti
saresti con i libri di storia serie
limita i liberi con difficoltà ma pian
piano da lima che abdica meno ciao ciao
a tutti innanzitutto vogliamo dirvi che
vi amo alla follia
il mio cambiamento più grande è
rappresentato dai miei capelli corti
dopo averli portati tutta la vita rooney
e lisci a 29 anni che ho scoperto un
tumore al seno ha fatto otto cicli di
chemioterapia e dopo averli persi tutti
quanti sono rivisto di superfici e ha
deciso di farli blu per festeggiare i
grado ma sono i belli per l'argento nel
fatto bene sarà bellissimo bacione un
abbraccio enorme che di sotto controllo
sempre ma come è giusto che qualsiasi
donna faccia fig applica a 16 anni ho
deciso di cambiare sesso
27 è stato più felice che mai il calo
dopo rosini lapidaria smom pantan dramma
diretta bello una fortuna enorme quella
anche di avere dell'immaginario dei
genitori e comunque a 16 anni riescono a
comprendere l'esigenza così grandi come
persona secondo me prova per arrivare
comunque a desiderare così tanto un
cambiamento di questo tipo quindi
chapeau purtroppo non è sempre così ma
cosa più bella è la serenità che sia
alla fine ed è brutto quando questa
serenità viene intaccata non tanto da un
tuo sentirti sbagliato sbagliata
sbagliate ma dall'esterno ed è brutto
quando alcuni questi percorsi di
accettazione e di crescita ed evoluzione
di cambiamento non vengano riconosciuti
comprese e accettate
sono saggio anche perché la vocalità
sembrava serena è in un momento sereno
salvo capito che le altre sono una
grandissima serenità la grandissima voce
di vita e la veduta mi sono messa a
dieta
l'anno scorso dopo la parentela con
deciso di consultare una nutrizionista
quando ricorda allo specchio mi sento e
mileto bella e credo che non ci sia
sensazione più bella e soddisfacente del
guardarsi allo specchio e piacersi
allora questo commento qua io so già che
rischierà di ricevere critiche o
attacchi dovute al fatto che è questa
ragazza si possa sentire più bella nel
momento in cui ha perso peso io vedo
molte persone che confondono questo
pensiero della bosico siti video
dell'accettazione in un bisogno di
doversi sempre a mare sempre voler bene
quello che legge la giornalista era
molto bello quando si parla di
accettazione non bisogna per forza
sempre dire anno il mio corpo nel corpo
almeno corpo perché ci saranno dei
giorni nei quali magari che vedrai più o
meno bello quello che veramente
importante è rispettare i corpi altrui
rendersi conto che ogni corpo presente
sulla faccia del pianeta ha lo stesso
diritto di rappresentazione di amore e
di rispetto
poi quello che la persona vuole fare del
proprio corpo il modo in cui lo vuole
vivere in modo in cui lo vuole abitare
sta a quella persona non state
giudicarlo in questo caso questa ragazza
aveva questa esigenza e secondarie un
messaggio bellissimo il nostro tempio ce
lo gestiamo noi però tu rispetta la mia
religione
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine
dell'ultima puntata di vita buttata sono
stati tre anni molto molto intensi molto
molto belli ma non riesco a essere
triste perché quello che sta per
arrivare con l'arrivo del nuovo ufficio
e del nuovo set di casa mi rende
contento per gli amanti del vero cuore
pulsante di vita buttata sarà una
ventata di freschezza quelli grazie
ragazzi per esserci
l'interazione titolare grazie a questa
stanza è stata il set di tanti tanti
video che abbiamo tirato da quando ci
siamo tutti quanti uniti all'interno di
questo percorso come le cose belle come
i film più belli a una fine e quindi in
brutti metteranno molto belli poi c'è
quel che solitamente sarà una mera
ragazzi un bacio grande ci vediamo
domenica una puntata in cui si è buttata
ciao ciao ciao
[Musica]